De lo que les quiero hablar es, cuáles son realmente los problemas más grandes del mundo.
No les voy a hablar del "Ambientalista Escéptico"
probablemente también un buen tema.
(Risas)
De lo que les voy a hablar es, ¿cuáles son los grandes problemas en el mundo?
Y debo decir, antes de seguir con esto, debo pedir a cada uno de ustedes
que intente sacar lápiz y papel
porque realmente les voy a pedir que me ayuden a examinar cómo hacemos esto.
Entonces, saquen lápiz y papel.
A fin de cuentas, hay muchísimos problemas en el mundo.
Sólo voy a listar algunos de ellos.
Hay 800 millones de personas muriendo de hambre.
Hay mil millones de personas sin agua potable.
Dos mil millones de personas sin saneamiento.
varios millones de personas muriendo de SIDA y VIH.
La lista se prolonga más y más.
Hay dos mil millones de personas que estarán severamente afectadas por cambio climático -- y demás.
Existen muchos, muchos problemas ahí fuera
En un mundo ideal, los solucionaríamos todos, pero no lo hacemos.
Realmente no solucionamos todos los problemas.
Y si no lo hacemos, la pregunta que creo nos debemos hacer es --
y es por lo que esto está en la sesión de economía -- es para decir,
si no hacemos todas las cosas, debemos realmente comenzar a preguntarnos,
¿cuáles deberíamos solucionar primero?
Y esa es la pregunta que les quiero hacer a ustedes.
Si tuviéramos, por decir, 50 mil millones de dolares para gastar en los próximos 4 años
para hacer el bien en este mundo, ¿dónde los deberíamos gastar?
Hemos identificado los 10 desafíos más grandes del mundo,
y sólo los leeré brevemente.
Cambio climático, enfermedades contagiosas, conflictos, educación,
inestabilidad financiera, gobernabilidad y corrupción,
malnutrición y hambruna, migración poblacional,
saneamiento y agua, y subsidios y barreras comerciales.
Nosotros creemos que estos, en muchas formas
abarcan los principales problemas del mundo.
La pregunta obvia sería,
¿cuáles cree usted, son los puntos más importantes?
¿Dónde deberíamos comenzar a solucionar estos problemas?
Pero esa una pregunta equivocada.
Eso fue realmente el problema que nos planteamos en Davos en Enero.
Pero por supuesto, existe un problema al pedirle a las personas que se enfoquen en los problemas.
Porque nosotros no podemos resolver problemas.
Seguramente el mayor problema que tenemos en el mundo es que todos morimos.
Pero no tenemos una tecnología para resolver esto, ¿cierto?
Entonces la clave es no priorizar problemas,
la clave es priorizar soluciones a los problemas.
Y eso sería -- por supuesto eso se complica un poco más.
Para el cambio climático sería Kyoto
Para enfermedades transmisibles, podrían ser clínicas de salud, o mosquiteras.
Para los conflictos, serían las fuerzas de mantenimiento de la paz de las Naciones Unidas, y así sucesivamente.
El punto que me gustaría pedirles que intentaran hacer,
es en tan solo 30 segundos -- y sé que es en cierto sentido
una tarea imposible -- escribir lo que ustedes creen
son algunas de las principales prioridades.
Y también -- y aquí es por supuesto, donde la Economía se torna malvada --
escribir cuales son las cosas que no deberíamos hacer en primer lugar.
¿Que debería estar al final de la lista?
Por favor, tomen sólo 30 segundos, tal vez hablen con su vecino,
y sólo piensen cuáles deberían ser las principales prioridades
y las últimas prioridades de la soluciones que ya tenemos
a las cuestiones más importantes del mundo.
La parte mas sorprendente de este proceso -- y por supuesto, me refiero,
Me encantaría -- Sólo tengo 18 minutos,
Ya les he entregado una cantidad sustancial de mi tiempo, ¿cierto?
Me encantaría profundizar, y ponerlos a pensar sobre este proceso,
y eso fue realmente lo que nosotros hicimos.
Y se los recomiendo fuertemente,
y estoy seguro que también tendremos estas discusiones luego,
para pensar acerca de: ¿cómo priorizamos realmente?
Por supuesto, uno se pregunta,
¿por qué diablos esta lista no se había hecho antes?
Y una razón es que priorizar es increíblemente incómodo.
Nadie quiere hacer esto.
Por supuesto, a toda organización le encantaría estar al principio de dicha lista.
Pero todas las organizaciones también odiarían no estar al principio de la lista.
Y debido a que hay muchas más posiciones que no son el primer puesto de la lista
que posiciones número uno, es perfectamente lógico
no querer hacer dicha lista.
Tenemos a las Naciones Unidas desde hace casi 60 años,
sin embargo nunca hemos hecho una lista fundamental
de todas las grandes cosas que podemos hacer en el mundo,
y haber dicho, ¿cuáles deberíamos hacer primero?
Entonces no significa que no estemos priorizando --
cualquier decisión es priorizar, entonces por supuesto todavía estamos priorizando
sólo implícitamente -- y es poco probable que sea tan bueno
a hacer realmente la priorización,
y nos sentáramos a discutirlo.
Entonces lo que realmente propongo es decir que hemos tenido
desde hace mucho tiempo, una situación como cuando tenemos un menú de opciones.
Existen muchas, muchas cosas que podemos hacer ahí fuera,
pero no tenemos los precios, ni los tamaños.
No tenemos ni idea.
Imaginen ir a un restaurante y tomar esta gran carta de menús,
pero sin tener la menor idea del precio de las cosas.
Ya saben, tomarse una pizza sin saber cual es el precio.
Podría ser un dólar, podrían ser mil dólares
Podría ser una pizza de tamaño familiar.
Podría ser una pizza de tamaño individual, ¿cierto?
Quisiéramos saber estas cosas.
Y eso es lo que el Consenso de Copenhague esta realmente tratando de hacer --
tratar de poner precios en estos elementos.
Y entonces básicamente, esto ha sido el proceso del Consenso de Copenhague.
Conseguimos 30 de los mejores economistas del mundo, tres en cada área.
Entonces tenemos tres de los mejores economistas del mundo escribiendo acerca del cambio climático.
¿Qué podemos hacer? ¿Cuál será el coste?
¿Y cuál será el beneficio de esto?
Esto mismo en enfermedades transmisibles.
Tres de los mejores expertos del mundo diciendo, ¿qué podemos hacer?
¿Cuál seria el precio?
¿Qué deberíamos hacer acerca de esto, y cuál seria el resultado?
Y así susesivamente.
Luego tenemos algunos de los mejores economistas del mundo,
ocho de los mejores economistas mundiales, incluyendo tres Premios Nobel,
reunidos en Copenhague en Mayo de 2004.
Los llamamos el dream team.
Los prefectos de la Universidad de Cambridge decidieron llamarlos
el Real Madrid de economía.
Esto tiene sentido en Europa, pero no realmente acá en Estados Unidos.
Y lo que básicamente hicieron fue una lista priorizada.
Entonces ustedes se preguntarán, ¿por qué economistas?
Y por supuesto, estoy muy contento de que se hagan esa pregunta -- (Risas) --
porque es una muy buena pregunta.
La cuestion es, por supuesto, si uno quiere saber acerca de la malaria,
le preguntas a un experto en malaria.
Si quiere saber acerca del clima, le preguntas al climatólogo.
Pero si quiere saber cuál de los dos debe abordar primero,
no le puede preguntar a ninguno de ellos, porque no es lo que ellos hacen.
Eso es lo que hace un economista.
Ellos priorizan.
Ellos hacen lo que en cierto modo es la desagradable tarea de decir, cuál deberíamos hacer primero,
¿y cual deberíamos hacer luego?
Entonces esta es la lista, y es la que quiero compartir con ustedes.
Por supuesto, la pueden ver también en nuestra página Web,
y hablaremos también más de ella, estoy seguro, a medida que pasa el día.
Ellos básicamente hicieron una lista donde dijeron
hay proyectos malos -- básicamente, proyectos
donde si inviertes un dólar, se obtiene menos de un dólar.
Luego hay proyectos justos, buenos proyectos y proyectos muy buenos.
Y por supuesto, son los muy buenos proyectos los que deberíamos comenzar a hacer.
Voy a comenzar al revés
así terminaremos con los mejores proyectos.
Estos fueron los proyectos malos.
Como pueden ver al final de la lista está el cambio climático.
Esto ofende a muchas personas, y es probablemente una de las cosas
donde las personas dirán "no debería volver", tampoco.
Y quisiera hablar acerca de esto, porque es realmente curioso.
¿Por qué será que salió esto?
Y también trataré de volver a esto
porque es probablemente una de las cosas
en las que estaremos en desacuerdo con la lista que ustedes escribieron.
La razon por la cual terminaron diciendo que Kyoto --
o hacer algo más que Kyoto – es un mal negocio
es simplemente porque es muy ineficiente.
No quieren decir que el calentamiento global no está ocurriendo.
No es decir que no es un gran problema.
Sino que es decir que lo que podemos hacer acerca de esto
es muy poco, a un costo muy alto.
Lo que básicamente nos muestran, el promedio de todos lo modelos macroeconómicos,
es que Kyoto, si todos están de acuerdo, debe costar alrededor de 150 mil millones de dólares al año.
Eso es una cantidad considerable de dinero.
Eso es dos o tres veces la ayuda al desarrollo global
que entregamos al Tercer Mundo cada año.
Aún así sería muy poco efectivo.
Todos los modelos muestran que esto pospondrá el calentamiento en alrededor de seis años para el 2100.
De manera que el tipo en Bangladesh que recibirá una inundación el 2100 podrá esperar hasta el 2106.
Lo cual es algo beneficioso, pero no muy beneficioso.
Entonces la idea aquí es decir, bueno, tenemos que gastar mucho dinero para obtener un escaso beneficio.
Y sólo para darles a ustedes una idea de referencia,
las Naciones Unidas en realidad estiman que por la mitad de esa cantidad,
alrededor de 75 mil millones de dólares al año,
podríamos resolver todos los grandes problemas básicos del mundo.
Podríamos entregar agua potable, saneamiento, atención básica sanitaria
y educación para cada ser humano del planeta.
Entonces debemos preguntarnos, ¿queremos gastar el doble de esa cantidad
para realizar tan escaso beneficio?
¿O la mitad de esa cifra realizando una cantidad sorprendente de bien?
Y esto es realmente por lo cual se convierte en un mal proyecto.
No es decir que si tuviéramos todo el dinero en el mundo, no quisiéramos hacerlo.
Sino que es decir, si no lo tenemos, simplemente no es nuestra primera prioridad.
Los proyectos justos – nótese que no voy a comentar todos esos –
pero las enfermedades transmisibles, la escala de servicios básicos de salud – justo pasaron,
simplemente porque, sí, escalar los servicios básicos de salud es algo grandioso.
Haría mucho bien, pero también es muy, muy costoso.
De nuevo, lo que nos dice es que de repente
comenzamos a pensar acerca de los dos lados de la ecuación.
Si se fijan en los buenos proyectos, muchos de los proyectos de sanidad y agua entraron.
De nuevo, saneamiento y agua son increíblemente importantes,
pero también cuestan mucha infraestructura.
Entonces me gustaría mostrarles las cuatro prioridades más importantes
que deberían ser con las que, al menos, deberíamos lidiar primero
cuando hablamos de cómo deberíamos lidiar con los problemas en el mundo.
Los cuatro mayores problemas son – enfrentarnos a la malaria.
La incidencia de malaria es de alrededor de 2 mil millones de personas infectadas cada año.
Puede incluso costar hasta un punto porcentual de PIB
cada año para las naciones afectadas
Si invirtiéramos 13 mil millones de dólares a lo largo de los próximos cuatro años,
podríamos bajar esta incidencia a la mitad
Podríamos evitar casi 500,000 muertes de personas,
pero tal vez mas importante, podríamos evitar que alrededor de mi millones de personas
se infecten cada año.
Incrementaríamos significativamente su capacidad
de enfrentarse con muchos otros problemas con los que deben lidiar.
Por supuesto, a largo plazo, también lidiando con el calentamiento global.
La tercera prioridad más importante fue el libre comercio.
Básicamente, el modelo mostró que si pudiéramos lograr el libre comercio,
y especialmente reducir los subsidios en Estados Unidos y Europa,
podríamos básicamente avivar la economía global
en una increíble cifra de alrededor de 2,400 miles de millones de dolares al año,
la mitad de la cual se acumularía en el Tercer Mundo.
De nuevo, la clave es decir que realmente podríamos sacar
de doscientos a trescientos millones de personas fuera de la pobreza,
de manera radicalmente rápida, en unos dos a cinco años.
Esto sería la tercera mejor cosa que hacer.
La segunda mejor cosa que hacer sería concentrarnos en la malnutrición.
No sólo malnutrición en general, sino que existe una manera muy económica
de lidiar con la malnutrición, esto es, la falta de micronutrientes.
Básicamente, a alrededor de la mitad de la población mundial le está faltando
hierro, zinc, yodo y vitamina A.
Si invertimos alrededor de 12 mil millones de dólares,
podríamos hacer una incursión severa en ese problema.
Esa sería la segunda mejor inversión que podríamos hacer.
Y el primer y mejor proyecto sería concentrarnos en el VIH/SIDA.
Básicamente si invertimos 27 mil millones de dólares durante los próximos ocho años,
podríamos evitar 28 millones nuevos casos de VIH/SIDA.
De nuevo, lo que esto hace, y en lo que se enfoca es decir
hay dos maneras muy diferentes de lidiar con el VIH/SIDA.
Una es tratamiento, la otra es prevención.
Y de nuevo, en un mundo ideal, haríamos las dos
Pero en un mundo donde no hacemos ninguna de las dos, o no lo hacemos muy bien,
por lo menos debemos preguntarnos dónde deberíamos invertir primero,
Y el tratamiento es mucho, mucho más costoso que la prevención.
Entonces básicamente, en lo que esto se enfoca es en decir que podríamos hacer mucho mas
invirtiendo en prevención.
Básicamente para la cantidad de dinero que gastamos,
podemos hacer X cantidad de bien con tratamientos,
y 10 veces ese bien con prevención.
Entonces de nuevo, nos concentramos en prevención más que en tratamiento,
en primera instancia.
Lo que esto hace realmente es que pensemos en nuestras prioridades.
Me gustaría que miraran su lista de prioridades y dijeran,
¿acertaron?
O ¿lograron algo cercano a lo que encontramos acá?
Bueno, por supuesto, una de las cosas es el cambio climático, de nuevo.
Veo que muchas personas encuentran muy, muy poco acertado que deberíamos hacer eso.
También deberíamos abordar el cambio climático,
entre otras razones, simplemente porque es un gran problema.
Pero por supuesto, nosotros no abordamos todos los problemas.
Hay muchos muchísimos problemas en el mundo.
Y de lo que me quiero asegurar es que, si realmente nos concentramos en algunos problemas,
que nos concentremos en lo adecuados.
En los que podemos hacer mucho bien en lugar de sólo un poco de bien.
Y yo pienso, en realidad – Thomas Schelling,
uno de los participantes del dream team, lo explico muy, muy bien.
Una de las cosas que la personas olvidan, es que en 100 años,
cuando estamos hablando de muchos de los impactos del cambio climático que habrán,
las personas serán mucho, mucho más ricas.
Incluso en los escenarios de impacto más pesimistas de las Naciones Unidas
estiman que la persona promedio en el mundo en vías de desarrollo para el 2100
sera tan rica como nosotros lo somos hoy.
Muy posiblemente, serán de 2 a 4 veces más ricas de lo que somos ahora.
Y por supuesto, nosotros seremos incluso más ricos que eso.
Pero la clave es decir, cuando hablemos de salvar personas,
o de ayudar personas en Bangladesh para el 2100,
es que no estamos hablando de personas pobres de Bangladesh.
En realidad estamos hablando de un holandés bastante rico,
Entonces la verdadera clave, por supuesto, es decir,
¿queremos gastar un montón de dinero ayudando poco,
para dentro de 100 años, a un holandés bastante rico?
¿O queremos ayudar a personas verdaderamente pobres, ahora, en Bangladesh,
que necesitan verdaderamente ayuda, y a quienes podemos ayudar de una forma muy, muy económica?
O como lo expresó Schelling, imagínese si fuera rico – como lo será usted--
un chino rico, un boliviano rico, un congoleño rico, en 2100
pensando atrás en el 2005, y diciendo, “Qué raro que les importara tanto
ayudarme un poco con cambio climático,
y les importara tan poco ayudar a mi abuelo
y a mi bisabuelo, a quienes hubieran podido ayudar muchísimo más,
y quienes necesitaban la ayuda muchísimo mas?”
Entonces pienso que esto realmente nos indica el porqué
necesitamos tener nuestras prioridades claras.
Incluso si no están de acuerdo con la forma típica de ver este problema.
Por supuesto, esto es principalmente porque el cambio climático tiene muy buenas fotos,
Tenemos, ya saben, “El Día Después De Mañana” – se ve grandioso, ¿no es cierto?
Es una buena película en el sentido que
yo ciertamente la quiero ver, cierto, pero no creo que Emmerich
tenga a Brad Pitt es su próxima película
escavando letrinas en Tanzania o algo así. (Risas)
Simplemente no sería suficiente para hacer una película.
Entonces, en diferentes sentidos, pienso en el Consenso de Copenhague
y en toda la discusión sobre prioridades
como una defensa de problemas aburridos.
Para estar seguros de que nos damos cuenta de que no se trata de hacernos sentir bien,
que no se trata de hacer cosas que tienen la mayor atención en los medios,
sino que se trata de hacer en lugares donde realmente podemos hacer el mayor bien.
La otras objeciones, creo yo, que son importantes de decir,
es que yo de alguna forma – o nosotros de alguna forma – estamos proponiendo una falsa elección.
Por supuesto, deberíamos hacer todas las cosas,
en un mundo ideal – Yo estaría ciertamente de acuerdo.
Creo que deberíamos hacer todas las cosas, pero no las hacemos.
En 1970, el mundo desarrollado decidió que íbamos a gastar
el doble de lo que veníamos gastando, ahora mismo, que en 1970 en el mundo en vías de desarrollo.
Desde entonces nuestra ayuda se ha reducido a la mitad.
Por lo que no parece que estemos en el camino adecuado
para resolver de repente todos lo grandes problemas.
Así mismo, la gente está diciendo, ¿pero qué pasa entonces con la guerra en Iraq?
Ya saben, gastamos 100 mil millones de dólares.
¿Por qué no gastamos esto en hacerle bien al mundo?
Yo apoyo eso.
Si alguno de ustedes puede convencer a Bush para que haga eso, estaría bien.
Pero la clave por supuesto, es todavía decir,
si consigo otros 100 mil millones de dólares,
aún queremos gastarlos de la mejor forma posible, ¿no?
Entonces el verdadero problema aquí es que volvamos atrás
y pensemos acerca de las prioridades adecuadas.
Sólo debo mencionar brevemente, ¿es ésta realmente la lista adecuada que obtuvimos?
Ustedes saben, cuando se pregunta a los mejores economistas del mundo,
inevitablemente se termina preguntando a hombres mayores, blancos, americanos.
Y ellos no tienen necesariamente, ustedes saben,
grandes formas de observar el mundo entero.
Entonces lo que hicimos fue invitar a 80 jóvenes de todas partes del mundo.
a que vinieran a resolver el mismo problema.
Los únicos dos requisitos fueron que estuvieran estudiando en la Universidad,
y que hablaran inglés.
La mayoría de ellos fueron, primero, de países en vía de desarrollo.
Todos tenían el mismo material, pero podían salir ampliamente
fuera del alcance de la discusión, y ciertamente lo hicieron,
para realizar sus propias listas.
Y lo más sorprendente fue que la lista fue muy similar --
con malnutrición y enfermedades en primer lugar
y el cambio climático al final.
Hemos hecho esto muchas otras veces.
Han habido muchos otros seminarios y estudiantes universitarios, y otras cosas diferentes.
Todo ellos terminan con una lista muy similar.
Y eso me da gran esperanza, realmente, al decir que yo creo
que existe un camino por delante que nos permitirá comenzar a pensar las prioridades.
Y decir, ¿qué es lo importante en el mundo?
Por supuesto, en un mundo ideal, nos encantaría poder hacer todo.
Pero si no lo hacemos, entonces ¿podemos comenzar a pensar por dónde deberíamos comenzar?
Yo veo el Consenso de Copenhague como un proceso.
Lo hicimos en el 2004,
y esperamos reunir a muchas más personas,
obteniendo mucha mejor información para el 2008, 2012.
Mapear la ruta correcta para el mundo.
Pero también comenzar a pensar acerca de la selección en política.
Para comenzar a pensar, “hagamos
no las cosas donde hacemos muy poco a costos muy altos,
no las cosas que no sabemos cómo hacer,
sino que hagamos las cosas donde podemos hacer enormes
cantidades de bien, a un precio muy bajo, ahora mismo.
Al final del día, pueden no estar de acuerdo
con la discusión de cómo hemos priorizado esto nosotros,
pero tenemos que ser honestos y francos, y decir
que si hay cosas que hacemos, hay otras cosas que no hacemos.
Si nos preocupamos mucho de algunas cosas
terminaremos no preocupándonos de otras cosas.
Entonces espero que esto nos ayude a priorizar mejor,
y pensar cómo trabajar mejor para el mundo.
Gracias.